foreign
or how to draw boundaries
for my own health around my grandmother
and helping her and it's making taking a
major toll on me where's her kids she
only had my mom and my mom just passed
away in September actually
[Music]
this is John from the Doctor John
deloney show
so glad that you're with us I hope your
New Year's going well hope your kids are
doing well I hope you're doing well if
you don't have kids you just have pets I
hope your pets are doing well
even your pets I hope everybody in your
life is doing all right and um
if they're not that might be why you're
here or maybe everybody's going great
and you are here because you just are
like wow at least that's not happening
whatever you have joined us um on the
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast ever I'm so grateful
that you're here thanks for joining us
um hopefully we have a wild show in
store for you today let's go to Thai in
Baton Rouge Louisiana what's up Ty
hey Dr Jay how are you today I'm good
man how are you dude
we're doing all right doing all right
awesome so what's up
so I'm sure we can go in a couple
different directions but I'll just start
my question and see where it goes okay
so how how can my wife and I come
together on the same page about
parenting decisions whenever we have
polar opposite upbringings
um in terms of well let me say it's good
I care less just off just on the face I
care less about where you've been and
more about unification about where
you're going
sure so tell me about
tell me about your past that make you
concerned that you can't get together
and go forward in the same direction
one thing I mean the example I want to
bring up is actually in relation to like
a recent event with our our son in his
sleeping habits okay
um a little before that so I grew up in
a household where I think was pretty
decent my parents were always present
they were always available and uh raised
us to be a very good independent adults
my wife again has the opposite to where
she grew up in a pretty volatile home
where one parent was probably
emotionally and verbally abusive and the
other was kind of a peacekeeper so she
has some Trauma from her past that I
think
I guess there are some experiences and
perspectives that very different from
mine
um
so that kind of manifests itself today
in that we have a two-year-old son we've
been together for about four years we
have a two-year-old son
and our opinion of his sleeping habits
are polar opposite in terms of
uh I don't think he has a healthy
relationship with sleep and she thinks
that the way that he sleeps or the way
that he doesn't sleep is actually
somewhat normal and we've been
struggling with this for a while okay
let's get to The Sleep issue but first I
want to say this pretty clearly
your
your childhood may have been free of
trauma or have much less trauma than
your wife's did
your
the resulting wisdom yours is not
Superior to hers
sure okay and she learned some
extraordinary lessons about connectivity
and love and hiding and fear and sleep
and things that you didn't learn because
your body didn't have to go to war every
day
and so there is a like just the way
listening to you talk about it your
childhood was Superior to hers and now
we've ended up in this issue and I can't
figure out why she can't see the way I
was raised just the right way and so why
can't we just do it like this
and so I want to be careful of that
train of thought okay because that gets
into mine is better and when mine is
better and you're talking to somebody
who's been through trauma
hers is yeah but I gotta survive and
then now you're talking about the war
you've been having for a couple of years
okay so let's think of Yes Man your
parents must do it they did an awesome
job great and her parents did a
miserable job true those are those can
both be facts
yet both of your wisdom that you've both
accumulated from you have a great
picture of what it looks like she has an
incredible picture of what survival
looks like that combination can make for
great parents when both of those wisdoms
are honored if one is is given
preferential treatment over the other
man you're talking about that's a recipe
for a mess so
um the the conversation about the sleep
we can get to it it's going to be less
of this particular issue and more of a
framework that you and your wife can
develop for how do we how do we uh make
decisions when we I want it one way and
he wants it the other way or vice versa
right so tell me about the sleep thing
so our son is about two years old okay
um he has since birth
um never I think been able to sleep
through the night I can count probably
on one hand probably that's happened
over the two years okay
um so we have a pretty good bedtime
routine where you know we have dinner
and then good bath time and then we
relax and in ease into the night and he
goes to sleep pretty well but
um he will not fall asleep on his own
and he will only fall asleep if he's on
one of us a rocking or nursing Etc okay
and then typically the the routine is
he'll wake up within a couple hours
after going down and then
he has again has to be rocked back to
sleep
oftentimes I'll start but he gets upset
with me because he wants to nurse and
then
over the night between 11 and up to 5
a.m he's waking up every hour and a half
or so and we'll only go back to sleep if
he's nursing or on one of us and so it's
it's been a challenge
um
so yeah
um and so do you want to just let him
scream and cry it out until he figures
it out or and she doesn't want that
well I think that's what's hard is like
we we do have some good conversations
we'll get into like the approach that
we'd like to use or the approach that we
think might be appropriate
um but again I think I like those
backgrounds and thank you for affirming
that because I will say that's one thing
that she's been phenomenal at is she is
very good at communicating her needs and
her experiences and and she's been uh
with the counselor for quite some time
and she I will offer she's been
extremely Brave and amazing and facing
her her past and working through those
things and I'm trying to be supportive
of her for all that
um
so
here's the challenge with
um babies and I'm gonna dude you know
this as well as I do when this comes out
do not look at the YouTube comments
because there's going to be a billion of
them okay yeah everyone's got an opinion
on sleep hygiene and sleep this and the
kids need to be whatever
my first impulse right wrong or
indifferent well here's my very very
first impulse is I'm not a pediatrician
and I'm not a children's sleep expert
okay and so finding a doctor that you
trust in your community that could give
you some
some what I would say some informed
guidance does he know y'all you and your
wife does he know your baby and the
particular uh you know
family history and blood
um you know uh details and dietary
habits can can he give you some or she
give you some informed guidance there
okay so that's important
beneath that is I like to trust a baby
yeah and if a baby is telling you I'm
not safe
something in my environment is telling
me I'm not okay
my first impulse is to ask me and my
wife what tension are we putting out
into the world in here that we've
created that this is an unsafe
environment for this kid to go to sleep
in
that may be an unfair and I don't say it
to blame it I just want I'm the adult
and I want to go look in the mirror
first before I start blaming a
two-year-old for not doing things to the
quote unquote right way does that make
sense
it does so I'm just creating a framework
is there attention and am I sleeping
through the night does my wife sleep
through the night right does I took I
took it off right before the show does
my do I track my sleep with like a whoop
strap and find out am I sleeping at
night at night or is my baby doing
exactly what I'm doing I've just learned
some tricks to cover it up in the middle
of the night or I don't fully wake up
you see what I'm saying
um so I want to look at at me and my
wife do we have anxiety in our home have
we created an anxious life and that this
baby is just mirroring
uh the the environment we've created for
it so if I ask you that does your wife
struggle from anxiety do you have an
anxious home are y'all struggling with
debt or connectivity issues or you and
your wife having a challenging marriage
season right now like what's going on in
your world
if we do struggle some debt we're
babysit too pretty deep
um but frankly I think we we're in a
good place like even though there are
some struggles and things we're working
through we we have a pretty good
a way to communicate and voice our needs
and and stay connected in that way uh
and I will say she she has recently
taken a couple steps to put in
boundaries in place with her parents and
you know based on some steps that she's
taking
um I know before we had him
um I mean she had some anxiety at that
would manifest at night and had trouble
sleeping uh this is another I'll just go
and own it um I've always had a really
good relationship with sleep and so this
is actually for me personally it's been
difficult because it's a way that I feel
like I can't connect with my son um
and so
um
sure so uh I was the kid where I would
go to sleepovers as a kid and I would
actually go to sleep a decent hour
instead of playing up staying up all
night playing video games
um
so I've always just had like a really
healthy relationships sleep and and
decent health habits Etc and so when I
see my son struggling with that at night
and I go to rock him and he he just
won't fall asleep like he'll just stay
awake for an hour or two hours just for
no what I think is no reason but
so it's hard for me to connect with him
that way because I'm trying to encourage
him or teach him and and I just don't
feel that I connect with him in that way
so let me tell you this man
he's two
yeah and you want to impart these wisdom
lessons and you want to give him the
best path forward he's just two he is a
bundle of nerves
that's what he is man he's a bundle of
responses he's slowly coming into his
own right so he's gonna get three and
four and five and you can check out
Piaget I mean you can find the the
stages of development right and he's
going to start transitioning here in the
next year or so and you're going to get
you're going to have a radically
different human a human with a
personality and he's got a personality
now but when he starts chit chatting
with you and talking and being silly or
being very serious you're going to watch
that emerge
what I would tell you if I could go back
man and just I'm saying this with all my
heart
is my son right now he's about he's
gonna be 13 in a few months
dude I
I over informed the first four years of
his life
and I under experienced it with him
I tried to give him a bunch of info and
make him do things the right way
instead of just honoring man he happens
to be a kid who he was the opposite of
your kid my son can go to sleep in the
middle of a of a train wreck
he's like all right good night and he's
out and dude I've struggled with sleep
my whole life and so there was times I
wanted to hang out and play and he just
was going to sleep he needed more sleep
than I needed
um and I thought I wasn't connecting him
that way and he needs to learn how to
toughen up and stay away dude I was it
wasn't him that was the Divine the the
the connection issue it was me
and so what I would tell you is making
peace with you are in a season say it's
the next six months say it's the next 12
months you are in a season Ty I'm gonna
get less sleep
and so I'm gonna have to be a little
more intentional about my discipline in
the morning when it comes to exercise
I'm going to be a little more
intentional about not snapping at people
because I'm going to be sleep deprived
because I got a little kid in the house
and I'm going to take advantage of those
couple hours when I quote unquote think
he should be asleep and he needs sleep
and it's best for him man a baby's body
knows
you know what I mean and make peace with
that because what he's going to do is
he's going to feel the tension from Dad
that something's not right and he's
gonna already internalize as a
two-year-old it's his fault he has to
solve this thing
and you don't want a two-year-old
carrying that kind of Burden you don't
want a five-year-old a 10 year old a 20
year old carrying that kind of bird
does that make sense
well it does and I can see that because
I know it has been manifesting for me in
other ways so like of Pat issues at work
and performance and
um even when I'm working from home I say
just I mean back to your other question
about tension in the house
um me working from home was very
difficult because I'm always feel like
I'm running behind or late because I'm
just I'm not at my best that's and
here's here's the thing is this your
first kid
it is yeah this is this is all of us
parents with our first kid and listen I
got a hard book deadline after the last
couple of days I was I've been writing
really early and writing home I just
booked a hotel for the next four days
I'm leaving my house because I can't do
it and I feel guilty that I'm leaving my
kids and I feel guilty of leaving my
wife
I can't do it and I can sit at home and
just be radioactive and not get any work
done or I just had to be a grown-up and
make other arrangements and it's gonna
cost money it's gonna cost all kind of
it just is it just is and so
I
there's a great lesson having a child
can teach us is how little control we
actually have over the world
yeah and the the quicker you come to
terms with how little power you have
the more peaceful your home will be
because right now you're fighting nature
you're fighting biology you're fighting
a two-year-old
and you you will lose that fight
and even if you win you lose
you see what I'm saying and so here's
what I would love and man I know you're
gonna dude you are gonna get blown up on
the internet on this I am too
about all different kind of sleep
training programs and blah fine yeah
whatever
all at the end of all of the programs
and then of all of the blog
I want to make peace with the kid in
front of me
and man I don't have I don't know many
kids that are more disciplined than my
kids they're very disciplined my kids
are they're great they follow the rules
are good kids and they're also
freakishly creative and silly and goofy
and fun because they're children and
it's me making peace with I my job is to
control every little thing make sure
they're on the right
my job is to make sure they don't kill
themselves make sure they're people of
value and integrity which means I gotta
live my life because they're watching me
and it means I've got to honor hey this
one wants to do gymnastics this one's
finding his place or her place in
theater and I thought they were going to
be a wrestler and I'm gonna go with them
in their Journey not force it does that
make sense and that's as little as as
you know what I'm gonna try for 30 days
just to make peace with the sleep thing
he'll go to sleep when he goes to sleep
and we're gonna honor that in the house
what we're going to do is instead of
focusing on managing his sleep schedule
we're going to focus on removing the
tension from the house
now dude I might be out to lunch it
worked in my home it might not work in
everybody's home but I would challenge
you to try that as you feel yourself
getting frustrated don't judge yourself
just be curious about like oh dude I'm
starting to get pissed again and he's
two I'm not gonna let him make me mad
because he's two
he's just not tired so we're getting the
trucks out
and we're gonna play trucks and I'm
gonna get two hours less sleep tonight
and I'm gonna have to really be
intentional tomorrow because I could be
it I could be not cool when I'm when I'm
sleepy
and we have a toddler we have a
two-year-old life just gets sideways and
so me and my wife are gonna have to
learn how to be married now with a
two-year-old
and I don't I I don't want to speak into
your life but I don't know many people
with a two-year-old whose sex life isn't
screwed up and whose communication
schedule isn't screwed up and who's
their ability to talk to each other in
this group and so there's something
important about going back to the well
with your wife y'all too and saying all
right
we got a new marriage now it's one where
we love each other and we're committed
to each other and I still think you're a
smoke show and you think I'm pretty
looking
and we have this human in our house that
will be with us forever and we gotta
learn how to be married again and then
you can have another kid and you have to
do this whole thing over again and then
you have a third kid you're gonna get a
dog and you're gonna have to all right
it's just gonna keep going
but don't try to get back to what your
marriage used to be because it's not
ever going to get back there you have a
new have a new marriage talk about what
that looks like create it you get to
create whatever you want
and in the meantime make peace with your
two-year-old son make peace with him
he's not operating on as much sleep cool
We There are seasons and I gotta lay
them down he's gonna cry for a minute
Babble about until he finally goes to
sleep
but the meta is not going to go to war
with him and when me and my wife have
when you and your wife I'll say that
when y'all have a challenge
let's go back to how do we create the
most peace in this home
what does that look like
and that might mean that we're gonna
sleep in different beds for the next
couple of weeks
or we're gonna try we just I want pizza
every Friday I can eat pizza because
when I eat pizza then and then I
breastfeed then he gets fussy I don't
know why he does he just does so I'm
gonna stop doing it we're gonna have to
make some sacrifices because our goal is
to have a non-anxious home
we have a non-exist home then people can
rest and they could sleep and then they
can fill in the blank so go seek that
seek a non-ex's home
and stop going to war with a
two-year-old my brother you're a good
dad man you are a good dad
and the faster you can learn that you
are have value as a father not because
of what you're gonna make your son do
but because you are always going to be
by your son's side the faster you learn
that the more peace your home will have
we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode sponsor better help
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is life
changing stuff but I'll be honest it's
not easy these are new skills that we
all have to learn and therapy is a great
place to practice these new skills and
that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right we are back let's go to Anna
in h-tone Houston what's up Anna
hi I'm doing okay how are you good go
Astros what's up
well I'm calling because
um I love your show and I've listened to
a lot of different things that have
helped me and
um I need some guidance here I really
feel like I'm I don't know what to do
right now let's do it let's do it let's
figure it out so I don't know where or
how to draw boundaries for my own health
around my grandmother and helping her
and basically
providing all of her emotional and
physical needs I make nearly all of the
decisions in her life
um and it's making taking a major toll
on me emotionally physically I'm hyper
stressed all the time I can feel it in
my body
um I've had to I've started paying for
the very expensive yoga membership
because I have to find a way to like
calm myself
um I I'm just I'm hopeless at this point
um because I feel stuck
um where's your kids
okay um I'm her granddaughter so she
only had my mom and
my mom just passed away in September
actually jeez I'm so sorry yeah
was that unexpected
he well yeah um not not shocking but
unexpected in that we didn't expect it
to happen
um they this goes into that but her and
my mom both sort of had a drug problem
like prescription pills and
um I made peace with the fact years ago
that my mom was probably gonna go that
way and
um that's what we think happened
um my grandma actually found her they
lived together my mom was living with
her for the past six to seven years
and they were kind of enabling each
other in this addiction and a lot of
dysfunction
and so my grandma found her uh one
morning
and um so that's that's kind of where
we're at there's been a huge shift
obviously my mom was living with her for
the past six to seven years at least
being there in the house to make sure
she had meals my mom could cook a little
bit my mom could clean up a little bit
my mom was someone in the house to like
wake her up and
be aware if my grandmother fell or
looked like she might be not waking up
and maybe took too many pills and my mom
would call 9-1-1 it was sort of like a
safety valve there you know
and now my mom is gone
um as dysfunctional as that was and how
much stress my mom's addiction and my
grandma and everything and her addiction
caused everyone that's not there anymore
right and um I've been taking care of
like the financial responsibilities for
my grandmother
for a long time she kind of checked out
of it was unable to keep up with it when
I stepped in it turned out my mom was
stealing tens of thousands dollars from
her over the years yeah yeah so um
what I'm going to say is going to sound
harsh okay
I want you to like know like you and I
are just hanging out okay so I'm talking
with you all right not at you
if your grandmother as an adult is an
adult who's struggling with addiction
is Gonna Act Like or is in a place where
she is acting like a child you are a
caretaker
you have to not be an enabler and you
have to be willing to make the hard
decisions that parents have to make for
their kids
what do I mean by that
you have to take an honest assessment of
her um financial situation
and that may mean that you got to sell
her house and move her into a a living
facility because you've you've
acknowledged it you cannot control
I mean you don't have the skill set for
it you're not you're not a stay-at-home
nurse you can't you're not living there
24 7 365 right you see what I'm saying
yes yeah I do I I don't have the skill
support for sure I don't have the
capacity and I don't have a skill set
the sort of sticker is that I can't make
her do any of those things you're
exactly right you know I can't force her
to sell our house she has the ability I
mean I don't have legal rights over that
she is she's with us she's a lucid
person if I were to take that to court I
don't have the money to make that happen
in court even if it would happen but
here's the deal
that means you have to make another hard
choice
choosing to
she at this I unders I've heard you say
this once to a caller that
um
someone in her family was treating her
like an anxiety Med every time they
picked up the phone and that show hit me
because that's what my grandma does like
times 10 for like all her stress her
problems yes she has just taken the the
dance she did with your mom
yes and let's be very very honest this
is hard to say
I can't imagine a scenario
where a parent who is co-involved with a
kid in reciprocal drug use and support
that that relational dysfunction hasn't
happened for so long that Mom learned it
somewhere
right I'm not sure if I totally feel
like you mean the relationship between
my mother I'm saying there must have
been an issue between grandmother and
mother to where your mom said the best
way I can get through my day is by is by
checking out with drugs yeah yeah my mom
had yes yes my mom had lots of problems
my grandmother had lots of problems
right and sometimes she was young your
grandmother lost her dance partner
and she just picked you up and said
let's go and you are dizzy from spinning
around so much right yeah and so what
you have to say you've heard me say this
on the show a bunch you've got to let go
of Grandmother for a second
go over
punch the DJ in the nose
or unplug the DJ system
um Turn All the Lights On and look at
your grandmother and say I'm not dancing
with you
if you want to live
you wanna have a good life
I'm going to help you make those
decisions that way
if you want to have somebody that every
day you wake up and you just drag
through the mud
who is serving as your human Xanax that
you want to do drugs with I'm not that
person
[Applause]
three months or so I haven't really seen
that happening I think that was a
function of my mom being around a large
part of it I do think that um is yet to
tell but at this point that's kind of
what I'm seeing let me say let me say it
this way let me see it this way
um propping up your grandmother will not
fix your relationship with your mom
okay
making trying to make right right now
doesn't heal that hole that's inside of
you
yeah I am definitely dealing with a lot
yeah I am dealing with my relationship
with my mom now that she's gone for sure
I'm yeah trying to come to terms with a
lot and I know that because you are
letting this Duty that you've created
for yourself pull you under water you're
gonna drown
I know but you're drowning trying to
save a ship that has no interest in
being saved
and but how do I do
needs help and care and we accept your
help and care
sometimes to a certain extent I want her
to get
help can she afford that
she can we can make that work
um At first she didn't want to she said
it was too expensive
um so my friend my friend Henry clouds
and this is a harsh way he says it but
he's right
your grandmother's never had to get home
health nurse or have anything that she
didn't want because she always had
somebody there
so the way Henry says Dr Cloud says is
um and he's usually talking about kids
is they got to get some problems
and at some point your grandmother has
to understand I love you and I will be
the the I'll be the uh the care manager
but I can't be the caretaker
so I will make sure that we have a good
contract with the home health nurse
company and that somebody's there and if
somebody didn't show up you let me know
and I'll make that phone call I cannot
be your home health nurse
and so hear me say I can't come over
three times a week
and as an adult who's Lucid she gets to
make her decision well then I guess I'm
just gonna fall and die here by myself
and there are some adults that will make
that choice
and it's I feel like that's the choice
she's making it's heartbreaking
but unless you want to go to court and
have her civil rights taken away
drowning yourself in this sort of pseudo
hero thing isn't gonna isn't gonna help
anybody you both end up underwater
I do feel that sense of like people say
to me we'll just just stop or don't do
it you're hurting yourself and you can't
do it all and it's like I can't
imagine where I don't
feel responsible for her I just can't
imagine I will but you are a person just
by listening to your story you're a
person who either ORS everything
I have to have the most expensive yoga
class or I can't make it that's not
right
that's that's a way you have chosen to
justify having a really rad yoga class
and that's great cool but there's
there's steps in between
either I go over there every day to make
sure she's not dead and she's taking her
medication or this whole thing that's
not true
you can go every you can go every Sunday
I'll come over for breakfast every
Sunday whether she wants you there or
not I'm coming over
and I'll listen to you complain away and
tell me all the things about great I'm
not going to be your emergency home
health nurse every time you call me I'm
just gonna call 9-1-1
thank you
and the moment you're ready for in-home
care I will be I'll be here to help set
that up
you see them so there's Middle Ground
between this I've got to be her
everything I've got to be doing things
that I'm not even qualified to be doing
like nursing things and medication
management oh that's I'm not even
qualified to do that
it's either that or I just your friends
are like well you just gotta tell her
just to screw off she got to do you
can't do that either I get I get what
you're saying yeah
but at some point you have to say hey
grandmother I am over my head
I can't manage I want you to have the
best possible life in the last few years
of your life and it's exceeding my
ability to manage it
I I have a set to her
um recently a lot you know very clearly
um yeah yeah of late becoming more clear
yeah because I
her response is sometimes like kind of
like you said like this very extreme
either or like well then I'll just take
you off all the accounts and you won't
have to worry about any of it and like
kind of manipulative child that's right
it's acting like a child that's right
if she takes you off she takes you off
and that will be heartbreaking and
you'll have to grieve it and it'll be so
sad and there's not a freaking thing you
can do about it
I'm afraid someone's gonna take
advantage of her if I'm not there listen
they will they will
but uh
you're creating scenarios that are never
gonna come or that might come down the
road if this happens and this happens
and that means this is gonna happen and
you are suffering them in the present
you're creating things down the road
that are going to be issues
if this happens and this happens and
here's what someone's going to take
advantage of her and you're gonna have a
stroke
both are true
and so
here's what I'll communicate to you the
greatest gift you can give your
grandmother right now
is that you be well
that you have enough capacity to help
her the to the best of your ability
and that means you have to Define
capacity what do you need what do you
actually need and you have to Define
what help what help you can you can
offer
and fine I'll just take you off
everything well grandmother you can do
that you and I both know that that's
immature and that you're just throwing a
temper tantrum if that's what you choose
to do then yeah you're an adult you can
choose to do that I hope you won't
because I love you and you're my only
family I got left and I want to continue
to help out there's just limits to how I
can help
and I know that there are I mean
gosh there's nothing more painful than a
than people in our Lives who make
choices and we know that those choices
are hurting them and at the end of the
day we can do very little about it
but I do know that going to war with
yourself when your body is telling you
you can go no further and you're like no
I'm gonna keep going it's unsustainable
and then man you've heard me talk about
this you end up resenting the fact that
your grandmother exists at all
and that's not where any relationship
wants no one wants their relationship to
end up there
and so make it clear here's what I need
make it clear here's how far I'm willing
to go make it clear
Grandma I'm still going to show up on
this day but I can't keep coming these
days express your needs very very
clearly I would probably recommend
writing them down and handing them to
her here is my schedule when I can start
coming to visit you
here's what I'm willing to do
and at the end of the day man
the things you can't control you're
gonna have to let go
and you're gonna have to grieve the fact
that you haven't let it go and I'm sorry
you got brought into this dance here at
the very end and man the music is
already going going and
your grandma's got a way of dancing and
either she's gonna change in short order
or there's gonna be mess down the road
I'll tell you this
she is the luckiest grandma on Earth to
have you as her granddaughter trying to
help out she's lucky to have you
but make sure Anna as well in this
process we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead
take a deep breath because Churchill has
your back check them out at
churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement in MLS ID 1591
nmlsconsumeraccess.org equal
housinglender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back what's up hey
before we move on hold on
the way you said that it's like
I'm in trouble nope that you're not I
just wanted to read an email we got and
I will not be reading the person's name
or anything that I found rather humorous
okay
just man your setup's amazing okay all
right question help me understand how
the jokes you tell about people loving
certain artists and having tattoos are
not white lies
I love your show and I feel challenged
to bring honesty to relationships even
the small things matter
as most of our listeners know
every time we do a lyric John makes a
joke
that I have that artist tattooed
according to him I have an Elvis tattoo
on my neck and I don't even know what
all but I'm covered in tattoos of
various band names
but I guess so this person is asking
how how am I not lying right
oh boy
I
here's I don't have an answer I don't
know how to
oh they're jokes people jokes I yeah I
look the horse noise just just
re-emerged you know what I'm okay with
that so
here's the thing
you gotta chill out uh I don't know how
to say like
they're not lies because I'm not trying
I'm having fun at the expense of my
friend
and
Kelly's one of my best friends in this
building and we Razz each other
constantly
and
hopefully here's how they're not White
Lies they're so absurd although certain
politicians may just say things that
you're like that's absurd
I don't have it I wish I had an answer I
don't know I'm just they're just jokes
we're just having fun so earlier okay as
those that are watching can see John has
on a beanie today oh yeah and I called
you Waldo
that is not a lie I'm not saying your
name is Waldo and you are Waldo it's a
joke okay so let's go down like I mean I
wish Dr Peterson was here we can just
Jordan we could just get on the we can
go to the rabbit hole here
philosophically
I when I say a lie I am trying to
convince you of something that is not
true
so that I have so that there's an
advantage for me is that it is that what
that would distinguish a lie
I think so because otherwise like Pixar
is just a building full of liars right
and because I really can't put balloons
on my house and it's going to float to
South America they're storytellers just
lying to us all right now they're
telling stories they're having or
comedians they're all liars right and
Harry Potter is all alive because magic
isn't real or whatever yes and preacher
is it well I mean
yes but like
it's telling stories and having jokes
play having having a good time
I
I don't know just start listening
audience knows I
none of those artists tattooed on me and
I am not angry that John says that I'm
okay with it and I would tell you that's
the first lie you've heard today Kelly's
covered in artist tattoos and covered in
even more cover-up makeup she has more
makeup on her neck arms back especially
lower back she's got so many lower back
tattoos covered and she just lied to all
of you so there you go there's your live
for the day Kelly hope you feel good
about yourself and that's not a little
white lie that's a big I feel pretty
darn good thanks a big red line what's
it what's the other LIE there's Little
White Lies what's the big lie
I don't know I don't know why you call
it Little White Lies but then there's
not a color to go with a big lie hmm not
that I'm aware of big fuchsia lies Big
Orange Line
Kelly tells them she is tatted out of
her mind and that leads us to actually I
don't know how to segue out of that
I don't even have to say
and I'm not trying to be ugly somebody
clearly is concerned about
um
me telling little lies about Kelly's
tattoos and favorite artists little lies
great song by Fleetwood Mac Tell me last
tell Mr hey you know what it's time for
it's time for facts of your friends
let's do it
it's the music of like in a movie when
there's a montage and a guy with a
mullet and leather pants like kicks open
the door he has no shirt on he's just
smoking that's that music play it again
that's just like hip Thruster music dude
stranger things no
anybody who knows what I'm talking about
Billy from stranger things that's his
that's his soundtrack massive awesome
yeah and it's a soundtrack to factor
your friends all right today we're going
to talk about
how to talk about sex with your partner
how to talk about sex how to talk about
sex Let's Talk About Sex baby all right
um a couple articles Kelly gave me here
one is from verywellmind.com one's from
psychologytoday.com
um different different ways to talk
about sex uh with your partner there's
several things in here
um
I have been having this conversation as
you can probably tell in the show in
fact it's funny my wife and I my wife
was talking to me about something oh
we're making uh the questions for humans
cards and we're making a sex and
intimacy deck and so I asked my wife to
like go through some of these with me we
were talking through them
and she had several questions that I had
written down she goes don't ask that I
was like why not and she goes just don't
ask it it makes the whole room weird
and I said I ask you that question I've
asked my friends that question people
come to the house asking those questions
and she goes yes and you've been making
rooms weird for years I was like really
she goes yes all of your friends know it
that you're the most awkward person so
I'm learning in real time
I just will have I just like talking
with everybody about everything and
there's very few if there's no things
that are taboo or weird for me
um I've learned in the last several
years that that's not the case
um with
just about anybody and so
I have also learned
um just meeting people all across the
country
um the show especially the calls that
come in the emails that come in
man there are few things going on in
um Western relationships right now like
challenges with sex and intimacy
particularly how to have these
conversations I like this I don't like
this I want to try this and there's so
much wrapped up into these conversations
and there's so much ego there's so much
shame there's so much I don't know
there's so much embarrassment
um we have the data is pretty clear
we've got it we are now there we have an
a generation of men getting married that
they have received their sexual
education from pornography and so they
understand sex ad they understand sex to
be something that it is not and
um there's very many a whole bunch of
women that have received that over the
not as much as the men the data says but
millions of women have received sex ed
or what they think is expected of them
and here and of course those are both
very generalized I know but so here we
find marriages are really struggling I
thought sex was gonna be like this and
she's like I know I thought sex was
gonna be like this and I thought and it
just turned into a quagmire and what we
do in our modern world is we don't have
any tools for talking about things we
just have enough distractions we just go
our separate ways and you've heard me
say this then you find yourself two
inches apart and two thousand miles away
from each other on the couch
um him on his device her on her device
and you're just in different planets
together and so there's something
incredibly profound
and uniting and quite honestly just a
ton of fun
learning how to talk about sex with your
spouse like we're going to talk about it
let's just talk about it and it ends up
becoming fun things to talk about silly
things to talk about serious things to
talk about
um but there's just ways to do it right
and so
um these two articles give a couple of
ideas um we'll link to them in the show
notes um they're not really scientific
if you will it's just some best
practices here
um there is a couple of things that come
from some data that I can that I'll I'll
bring out but here is
what I'm going to suggest here's several
I wrote down seven things
seven rules if you will for talking
about sex with your spouse the Romantic
party
um here's number one set specific times
to have this conversation designated
say the words we're going to talk about
sex on Friday
we're gonna go to dinner and talk about
sex we're gonna talk about sex on
Saturday on a long walk where we're
sitting next to each other and we don't
even have to look at each other in the
eye but we're going to talk about it
we're going to practice that way
don't spring it on somebody or when you
get frustrated or you don't feel self I
mean you're feeling self-conscious and
you take your shirt off man I'm talking
about male or female and it's like do
you think I'm attractive do you know or
what's that old joke like you know
you're rolling over to go to sleep and
then one of you you know your wife Taps
you on the shoulder and she's like if I
didn't have any arms and legs but you
still want to be with me like don't do
that that's not a productive
conversation that's a way to get a
reaction out of somebody and this is not
a great conversation for reactions it's
a good conversation to have um when
everybody knows it's coming and we are
prepared for it so set a specific time
um if you need to like set it up like
Hey we're gonna talk about budgets and
then we're going to talk about this and
we're going to talk about the state of
our sex life it might be a five minute
conversation it might be a 20 minute
conversation that would be two hours
great
um and by the way you think when you've
been married three years that you've
talked about everything you haven't
things begin to shift and morph and hey
I heard about this and I saw all this
and remember that couple in that movie
yesterday do you want to try that or
what did you think about that or that
was weird I heard this at work the
conversations will continue to evolve if
you make it a regular part of your
relationship interaction so set specific
times number two own the awkwardness
the more you own the awkwardness start
the conversation this is gonna be weird
or this is going to be awkward or I've
never talked about
uh I've never talked about my body parts
with somebody else before I've never
admitted this before I've never talked
about masturbation with somebody else
before I've never talked about this my
number of partners with somebody I've
never talked about owning just own the
awkwardness just own it this is gonna be
awkward and then as you speak in into a
like a uh you speak these things out
into the world you're honest about these
things often for the first time out loud
and you're telling them to somebody who
has looked you in the eye and told your
friends and your community and your
families and God if you're a religious
person I will always be here I won't
leave you
and then you can begin to have these
honest real deep conversations about
yeah this is kind of what I'm into this
is what I'm about this is what I like I
wish I didn't have this past but I do or
I wish I experienced this thing
own the awkwardness okay that's number
two it's gonna be weird
good
number three
be specific
God Almighty we've got so many words for
so many different body parts and so we
talk in circles about you know it's kind
of really
here's what I mean I don't like it when
your tongue does x y z
or whenever you kiss me you do it too
hard
I don't I wish you kissed me gentler or
hey try this or can we try this or I
love it when
I love when you touch me here when there
are dishes and by the way it doesn't
have to be just about body parts such
and body parts when there are dishes in
the sink
I my body can't fully relax
when you and I are fighting and I know
we had put a little star on today on the
calendar when we're having a fight I
just can't get into it
um we need to have this conversation
first
so be specific and practice being
specific I like this thing and for many
of you when you say I like this thing
you're going to turn beat red your
heart's gonna start beating all weird
and especially
ah when I say I don't like this thing
which leads me to number four
practice this
practice
not getting your feelings hurt
when your husband when your wife tells
you I don't like this
and they do it in a loving way obviously
they can be mean about it and be cruel
but when somebody tells you in a loving
way
they are giving you insights into their
soul into the things that bring them
happiness in eroticism and pleasure and
joy
rejoice in the fact that you've got some
new data some new tools like some new
ideas for moving forward and that you're
not doing something that your partner
doesn't like because if you're doing
something they don't like or in a way
they don't like
if you put on a cologne and you get like
your leather vest and no shirt you're
like yeah and you like shave a mustache
and you're like this it's it's party
time weekend and you put that music on
they were just playing
and your wife is like oh God I hate
and then sex is weird and it's awkward
and you're all super weird in the music
you're playing is awful like
wouldn't you rather
hey when you like go down that road it
makes me so uncomfortable it makes me
think about X or why or it makes me feel
this way I would love to try this
and then
man you can be into it and she could be
into it everybody can be into it and it
changes all Dynamic so I this is
generalized statement okay this applies
to more than just men but
more men than I hear from women whenever
I say hey I would like to try this or
instead of this could we try this that
men get their feelings so hurt guys can
be the worst with their egos like and
they got their sex from pornography so
they think sex is supposed to be like
this
and it's not
it's not
and
so Men set your ego down
and women set your ego down
this is about learning and listening and
trying to honor your partner this isn't
about being right or this is the way we
oh man
no hurt feelings okay the best you'll be
like if somebody's cruel and they try to
hurt your feelings well you suck at this
or my old boyfriend used to do this
better than well yes you should have
your feelings hurt because someone's
just being cruel
okay
um so be curious be curious
um
I don't
we may have to edit this out okay
along the hurt feelings I remember
talking talking to
um
[Music]
I was talking to a couple ones several
years ago
she thought she was
amazing
and
with a particular move that she had
according to him the move was not
amazing it was awful it was so painful
and
he didn't want to hurt anybody's
feelings and just kind of like was like
and just endured it until finally he
started to stop start avoiding sexual
contact altogether
because it really hurt I'm only laughing
because listening to them tell the story
was a riot they're both super funny
people
um
and she said the greatest gift she
received is when he said you have to
stop doing that it hurts so bad stop
what and then when she found out that
she wasn't hurting him anymore
that was a gift to her and yes she was
embarrassed like crazy I can't believe
this went off her and she was also kind
of pissed you let this go on this long
without telling me this hurt instead of
us wasn't awesome yes I did I was
embarrassed and then that kind of set
the stage four doors can talk about
everything because there's no reason to
just endure this this way right so there
you go
um all right number five don't
replay or dig for performance reviews
don't like after a sexual encounter
don't be like all right was that an A or
a b or a c Varsity moves don't do that
this is about relationship stuff now if
you want to compliment your partner
great if you want to when you're talking
about it a couple of days later or a
week later
um hey the other night that was
incredible or hey I said I would try
this thing one time I did not dig it I
didn't dig it it wasn't great it wasn't
fun
um I'm not super interested in doing
that again what did you think I loved it
uh well like man I'm glad you did but it
wasn't I wasn't into it
um when you start Play by playing in the
moment
um the act of sex itself is such a
vulnerable intimate engagement
right afterwards is such a release of
neurological chemicals it's a physical
it is not a time for Learning and for uh
critique
it's a moment for
and so if you're is critiqued to be
given if there's conversations to be had
a take critique out of it and if you are
insecure about hey did you like that
what did you think about that the number
of people who have told me I can't stand
it will my husband and wife asked me how
was it what'd you think was it pretty
awesome don't do that don't do that
create an environment in your
relationship where they'll let you know
I'll tell you if I mean it was it was
awesome do we need to go down the I
thought you knew it was awesome when I
was yelling or I was smiling or I was
like whatever was going on in in there
at the time so
um don't dig for performance reviews
okay be at peace and if something's
awesome if you're partner does something
new or something Incredible or awesome
or what is Meaningful or felt right or
you felt super connected say that say
that and by the way again it doesn't
have to be about some sex thing it can
be hey last night start to finish
you helped out with bedtime with the
kids
man you just went like it really helped
out with the with the uh
dishes I got to take a long bath it was
incredible dude the whole night I felt
super connected I felt seen I felt loved
I felt it just connected say those
things those are awesome six have soup
tons of fun have fun with the
conversations okay have fun
um ask each other about fantasies what
are you what's like a thing you've never
told anybody that you you would never do
it but you would like like I'd want to
know I don't know what to be like
um what are some things that like I
heard about this once like have you ever
heard about it like have those come that
can be so fun it can be erotic in itself
having the conversation like oh my gosh
my wife is talking to me about this my
husband's talking about yes have those
conversations
um I've talked about this on the show
The Erotic envelope system it's
sometimes hard
to say hey
honey I want to try this particular sex
move or I want to try this particular
that's hard it's awkward it's weird so
uh the idea was get 10 envelopes for 50
cents at Walmart or Walgreens and you
take five and she takes five or vice
versa and you write down I want to try
this
and I just want to try it it
the rule is you got to be curious not
judgmental you can't be like oh my gosh
you sick for unless unless it's like
whoa whoa right but
be like what okay I don't know how how
this works I don't know how we can make
this happen I'm in I'm down
um I'm just curious tell me about it
tell me about like the talk about what
you want and everyone listening to this
you have a thing they just pop into your
head that's why I'm not telling you uh a
couple of ideas because I just want you
to go with whatever just popped into
your head
um and sometimes it's I'll just tell you
like me and my wife did this we
one of hers was french kissing
I miss just french kissing
and I was like
uh okay
so we french kissed and it was kind of
awesome it was awesome it was awesome
okay last one
um
over the course of this conversation
be honest about pain
about past hurts if you are a abuse
Survivor and there's a context of safety
in your relationship and your marriage
or if you're with the counselor be
honest about things that bring you pain
discomfort that make you
um feel less than
okay whether that's a request for a
particular sex act whether that is a way
your partner's approaching you whether
that's a way like whatever like be
honest about things happen in your past
be honest about pain
okay and I made light of it earlier
um just because that particular
situation the two people are hilarious
but there's a lot of time Pain's not
funny at all not even a little bit
in fact it's disturbing and someone
needs to raise a flag and say hey I'm
not comfortable with this this hurt stop
um or this reminds me of the way a
former girlfriend talked to me and it
makes me super uncomfortable a former
boyfriend used to do like I'd stop stop
right
um be very honest about your pain okay
so that's seven
seven things seven ways you can talk
about sex with your partner please make
this a regular part of 2023 for you and
like for you your smiles like talk about
it talk about it talk about it
man having the conversations be willing
to be curious to judgmental having fun
with this man you can change your life
we'll be right back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we are back and um Kelly does
not have a tattoo
of Marvin Gaye
that we know of
and she won't know
what she does ladies and gentlemen she
does
probably an Old English down the side of
her leg
yeah
no the song of the day in honor of the
last segment back to your friend segment
song is Let's Get It On It goes like
this I've been really trying baby trying
to hold back this feeling for so long
and if you feel like I feel baby
I've never listen to the lyrics of the
song then come on
oh come on let's get it on baby
[Music]
we're all sensitive people with so much
to give understand me sugar since we've
got to be here let's live I love you
[Music]
Let's Get It On
America we'll see you soon